- We are back and it's we love LA week
and we've got Shaquille O'Neal
and Dan Reynolds with us.
Give it up.
(audience cheers)
Shaq, is a pretty, chill guy.
So chill, in fact, sometimes it's hard
to tell if he really loves
something or isn't that into it.
Well...
(audience and Kelly laughs)
It's time to get to the bottom
of that eternal question,
what does Shaq love?
With a little game, we're calling...
(upbeat music)
♪ Love Shaq ♪
(audience cheers)
Exactly.
We're clever, we are very clever.
It's pretty simple, I'll
hit this button, what?
A list of three things
will pop up on the monitor
and Dan and I will guess,
which of those three things,
we think Shaq loves most.
Then, Shaq will reveal to us who is right,
which will probably, be me and why.
Okay, if we're right, we get a point.
Here we go, are you ready?
- I mean, I've known Shaq for years,
so I already, I already know
I'm going to win, but whatever.
- I still think I'm
going to win, watch this.
(beep)
(bell rings)
Okay, which female artists
does Shaq love most,
Whitney, Beyonce or Ariana?
Ooh, he's writing it down
Here's the thing.
- You're looking at like,
what letter he's drawing,
I saw that.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] What? I'm not.
- He was like, doing the circle thing
and you were like, "Hey".
- No he's right, no when
I say things I'm ADHD,
I just look at what I'm saying.
- There's definitely an "O"
There's definitely an "O"
I'll tell you right now.
- Oh, there is? Were you looking?
You were looking.
- I mean, I was looking at you looking.
- You're a cheater.
(Kelly laughs)
No, okay, so what do you think?
Which one do you think?
- [Dan] I mean, I told you,
I already know the
answers to all of these.
So, let me just preface this.
If I don't get it right, it's
because he's lying about it.
Just so you know.
(audience laughs)
It's a 100 percent, it's C,
but you know, go with what you want.
But it's C.
- Wait, what?
Here's the thing, I love C.
I love Ariana and I love Beyonce,
but how do you not choose
Whitney Houston, when she's in...
The other two were like inspired by,
like, I don't know, like...
- Well, because he's told
me, he's told me it's C.
- I need you to know
I'm going to judge you,
if it's not Whitney.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay, so...
- All right, all right, all right, it's B.
It's B, it's B.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- It's B, it's B, I'm
just going to tell you.
- Do not do that, he chose...
- I was trying to throw you off.
- [Kelly] He chose Ariana.
- No, no, no, I was
trying to throw you off.
B, final choice B.
- That's the final choice.
- Are you serious?
- B, yeah B, but you stick with A.
- Dan Reynolds is a cheater.
- No, no, no, no, B.
- Oh, my gosh, reveal your answer.
- I hate to say Dan, you
were absolutely correct.
(bell rings)
- Oh, my gosh.
- And Kelly you were wrong.
Beyonce.
- [Dan] I told you, the "O", the "O".
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- [Shaquille] Yes, Beyonce, all day.
- Here's the thing, I
know, I love Beyonce,
but like Whitney?
- [Shaquille] I love Whitney,
I love Whitney, rest in peace.
- [Kelly] Apparently not enough, Shaq.
- And I love Ariana, but Beyonce.
- [Kelly] No Beyonce is... She's amazing.
Okay.
(ding)
Here we go.
(bell rings)
Okay, so which delicious morning,
beverage does Shaq love most,
orange juice, coffee or tea?
Hmm, okay, I'm going to say,
for some reason, I want to say, like,
I think it'd be funny if it was tea,
because just to see him drinking,
like a little cup of tea,
but I think it's orange
juice, orange juice.
I'm going to say orange juice.
He seems like a healthy guy.
- Well, I can tell you for sure.
I can tell you for sure,
it's not A, it's not A.
- [Kelly] No.
- [Dan] It's definitely not
B, I know that for sure.
(audience laughs)
So, it's C, absolutely.
- [Kelly] You're going to say C?
- Yeah, no, no, if you
want C though, I'll take A.
(Dan laughs)
Do you want to take C? I'll do A.
I'll do A, you C, final answer.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] I love you.
Okay, I'm going to say,
him drinking a tiny, bit
of tea would be funny.
- [Dan] That would be funny.
- I'm going to say tea, tea, yeah C.
- Kelly, you are absolutely wrong.
(bell rings)
It's A.
(Dan laughs)
(audience applause)
Good job, Danny boy.
Good job.
- Are you serious? What's happening?
- Tea, I don't drink tea.
- Oh, my God, I've been scammed.
Your style of playing games,
I'm kind of into it, man.
I'm kind of into it, oh my God, oh my God.
Okay, here we go, here we go.
(ding)
Whatever.
You're not stealing my answer this time.
- I came to win.
- Whatever.
Which comedy does Shaq most like to quote,
"The Hangover", "Step
Brothers" or "Caddyshack"?
I'm not listening to either one of you.
(audience laughs)
Okay, which one do you think?
- [Dan] No, no, you go, ladies, first.
- You are so...
(Kelly laughs)
I'm going to say, I really want it
to be "Stepbrothers",
B, because it's funny.
- [Dan] You're just trying to win now.
- No, whenever he says...
- You're just trying to
win, whatever, it's fine.
- [Kelly] "The Mists of
Avalon", when he comes...
- You're wrong about it, so it's fine.
You can have B.
- I am taking B and you're
not taking it from me.
- I want you to have B,
I've thought about it being C,
but I will tell you,
I will give you C, if you want to C.
(Kelly laughs)
- I want B.
- I'm going to go B, too.
We'll both go B, why not?
- Okay, fine.
- Why not?
- I hate y'all, I hate y'all.
- I'm not doing nothing.
(audience laughs)
I'm just sitting here.
- Oh, you ain't do nothing, you damn liar.
(Kelly laughs)
- What'd you pick, B?
You picked B?
- I did pick B, yes.
- I picked B.
- You both were correct, "Stepbrothers".
(bell rings)
- Yes, "Stepbrother".
(audience cheers)
That's a good... Oh, I can't.
(Kelly laughs)
One more and the last
one is for two points.
Here we go.
(ding)
- Hey, that's cheating.
- It's my show, get over it.
- Why do you make it for two?
- Build a bridge.
- Okay, all right.
(ding)
I see how it works.
- Okay, what gadget does Shaq love most,
his blender, his turntables
or his police siren?
- Dan, I could see you
getting this one right.
- [Dan] All right, okay.
- Dan, I can see you
getting this one right.
- [Dan] Okay, all right, all right.
- I, I...
- I'm going to go with C.
(Dan laughs)
I'm going to go with C.
No, no, don't copy me.
I'm know but here's... I kind of,
wanted to have a police siren.
- No, no, no, no.
I'm just going to tell you,
for sure, look, his turntables.
- I know, I know, he's a dealer.
I get that, I get that,
but wouldn't it be funny if
he'd like... You know what?
You should show up with
turntables and the siren.
- No, no, no, I already chose C.
Only one person, It's the double round.
You said on the double round,
I only can... One person can choose it.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- You're my favorite person,
I've ever played a game with.
Okay, I happen to choose, B.
- Don't do it out of pity,
don't do it out of pity.
(Kelly laughs)
- Do you want C? I'm going
to give you C, if you want.
- I'm taking C.
- Okay, you know what? Have C.
- His police siren.
- I'm going to give
you this one, actually.
- Okay.
- I'm just going to go with...
- Oh, that's so kind of you.
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm going to go with A.
For me...
(audience laughs)
I'm going to go with A.
(Kelly screams)
(bell rings)
- You are correct.
(Kelly and Dan scream)
(horn wails)
- I love my blender, in the morning.
(audience cheers)
Oh, man, I love my
blender, in the morning.
- Oh, God.
This is, hands down, my favorite game,
I've ever played on the show.
Well that means, that Dan is a cheater.
(audience laughs)
Wait, that means that Dan,
is the big, "Love Shaq" winner, y'all.
That also means, following the show,
Dan's photo will be hung on the
Blake Shelton Wall of Champions,
who beat Kelly Clarkson,
because you cheated.
(audience cheers)
Dan Reynolds and Shaquille
O'Neal, y'all, give it up.